die bundesinnenministerin die hat jetzt
aktuell bei einem fluchtgipfel auf
europäischer Ebene nicht teilgenommen
weil sie gesagt hat wir haben ja aktuell
gar keine migrationskrise Stimmen sie zu
sie hat einen schwarzsekretär geschickt
ich war bei den EU-Minister
Gipfeln immer selbst dabei auch wenn ein
Thema nicht wichtig war da hat man da zu
sein als Bundesminister im
Ministerrat der Fall wichtige
Entscheidungen die man hinterher wenn
sie nicht richtig laufen auszulöffeln
hat Kollege Michael Müller weiß es
regierende ehemaliger Bürgermeister von
Berlin davon ein Lied zu singen denn es
ist nicht nur Bundesrecht sondern auch
landesrechte es gibt im Moment keine
große migrationskrise wie sie das gesagt
hat dann ist die Frau irgendwo vom
anderen sterben sie möchte am
Ministerpräsidentin in Hessen werden
aber so wird es bestimmt nicht wer Augen
im Kopf hat und jemand wie ich erlebe
der sehr täglich bei meinem
Bürgermeister und 50 Bürgermeister in
meinem Wahlkreis ganz im ganzen Zipfel
von Bayern wenn ich das so sagen darf
wie das klingt der letzte Titel von
Bayern wo die Leute am allerliebsten in
Urlaub hin von Berchtesgadener Land und
Chiemgau nein da kommen da kommt
natürlich die Balkanroute an von
Salzburg über die bayerische oder
deutsche Grenze und dann werden jetzt
die Turnhallen der Schulen und so weiter
voll gemacht im
Mehrzweckräume der Gemeinden und da
kommt richtig Stimmung auf und wenn die
dann hören von der deutschen
Innenministerin da ist findet nichts
statt dann fühlen die Leute sich
natürlich verschaukelt wie kann man als
Ministerin Frau Zimmermann offenbar wie
Herr Ramsauer das schildert so daneben
liegen
also ich würde mit ein bisschen
sachlicher umgehen ich weiß jetzt nicht
warum ob das der einzige Grund war das
kann ich jetzt auch nicht beurteilen
nein ich finde Herr Ramsauer sie sind
erfahren und wissen dass
Ministerinnen und Ministern
möglicherweise war was anderes ist es
geht gar keine Rolle Aussage
migrationskrise ja oder nein das kann
ich gar nicht beurteilen
in der Tat ist es so dass wir momentan
1,2 Millionen ukrainische Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland haben neben Polen und
anderen Nachbarstaaten sind wir das Land
was am meisten aufgenommen hat das liegt
auch an der Nähe natürlich zu Ukraine
wir wissen ja bei Fluchtbewegung gehen
die Menschen sozusagen gar nicht weit
weg in absoluten Zahlen haben wir so
viel aufgenommen
dass Menschen natürlich als sogenannte
Binnenflüchtlinge in der Nähe zumindest
das eigene Landes bleiben in der
Hoffnung dass sie wieder zurückkehren
und in der Tat momentan steigen die
Zahlen nicht
angesichtsdrama sie haben es ja gerade
gezeigt dass Putin ähm jetzt versucht
nachdem die Militär auch nicht den
Erfolg hat den er glaubte nicht nur die
Menschen zu quellen und umzubringen das
ist ja unvorstellbar was ich da abspielt
sondern er möchte natürlich eins
erreichen er möchte dass durch die
Migration der Einhalt der Europäischen
Union der Einheit des eigenen Staates
unterminiert wird also auf gut deutscher
Weg aufeinander losgehen wegen dieses
Thema sagen sauer hat ja schon mal ein
gutes Beispiel gerade gebracht das
sollten wir eben abwehren und zeigen
dass wir auch in einer solchen Zeit
natürlich überlegen müssen ich komme aus
der Kommunalpolitik wie können wir damit
umgehen aber wir sollten nicht
gegeneinander Rennen sondern wir sollten
uns in Acht nehmen das narratives
Wladimir Putin nicht zu bedienen ja wir
müssen aber offen natürlich über die
flüchtlingskrise die wir offenbar ja
aktuell haben über eine Millionen weit
über eine Million insgesamt rund 1,2
knapp 1,3 Millionen aus der Ukraine die
UNO warnt massiv vor vielen vielen
weiteren Millionen Flüchtlingen wenn die
Lage so dramatisch ist aktuell in der
Ukraine nach der das im Moment aussieht
Herr Lafontaine wenn dann die deutsche
Innenministerin eben sagt wir haben doch
im Moment gar keine große
migrationskrise in Deutschland was sagt
das über die ja Flüchtlingspolitik in
Deutschland aus ihrer Meinung nach
ich finde das sehr bedauerlich denn die
Zahlen sind ja eindeutig
wir müssen überlegen wie wir jetzt die
Situation lösen können und für mich gibt
es nur eine Antwort wir müssen
schnellstmöglich ein Waffenstillstand
erreichen wenn wir den Menschen die in
der Ukraine sterben helfen wollen die
die dort verletzt werden und die
Menschen jetzt frieren das ist der beste
Weg und ich freue mich dass der oberste
Soldat der USA mag Mille der
Generalstabschef jetzt gesagt hat wir
brauchen endlich Verhandlungen und
müssen zu einem Waffenstillstand und
einen Frieden kommen das ist die
richtige Antwort das heißt sie würden
jetzt noch vor dem Winter große
Zugeständnisse an Moskau machen
man muss verhandeln was bei den
Verhandlungen herauskommt wird man dann
sehen aber versuchen muss man es denn
ein Waffenstillstand wäre die beste und
die größte Hilfe für alle Menschen die
jetzt leiden
angesichts dieser humanitären
Katastrophe Frau Zimmermann ganz schnell
zu entlassontainer sagt jetzt bevor wir
weiter diskutieren ganz schnell nach
Moskau fahren und Verhandlungen
aufnehmen
angesichts dieser Katastrophe die sich
da möglicherweise anbahnt der richtige
Weg na ja das ist die Welt des Oscar
Lafontaine dass man offensichtlich einen
guten Draht hatte früher und dann mal in
Moskau anrief
in der Tat es gibt zwei Szenarien die
Russen hören umgehend auf ziehen sich
zurück aus der Ukraine dann ist der
Krieg sofort und umgehen beendet oder
die Ukraine wehrt sich nicht mehr dann
ist die Ukraine von der Bildfläche
verschwunden das sind die Alternativen
momentan und insofern ist es unsere
Aufgabe die Ukraine in ihrer
Wehrhaftigkeit zu unterstützen und uns
eben auch so wie möglich uns Flüchtlinge
natürlich im Kontext Europas zu kümmern
wir sprechen über die flüchtlingslage
Knaus und sie forschen zu diesem Thema
seit vielen Jahren sind vielleicht in
Europa der migrations der
flüchtlingsexperte was droht dort sie
sprechen von dem historischen
fluchtwinter was bedeutet das in Zahlen
naja was wir jetzt schon haben ist die
größte Zahl von Flüchtlingen die seit
den 40er Jahren also seit auch danach
Kriegszeit das sind ja Millionen in
deutsche auch nach Deutschland das
Flüchtlinge gekommen aber seit den 40
Jahren hatten wir so etwas noch nie
erlebt und das ist jetzt schon die
Situation und wie frau Zimmermann ja
auch klar sagt es ist eine politische
Strategie die fluchtursache ist hat
einen Namen das ist Wladimir Putin sein
Ziel ist es Europäer und das ist
vielleicht die letzte Karte dir noch
spielt weil die der Terror hat die
Ukraine bis jetzt nur entschlossener
gemacht weiter zu kämpfen aber seine
Hoffnung ist die Europäer zu spalten
dass die Europäer die Ukraine fallen
lassen und dazu setzt er auf Zerstörung
der Infrastruktur er hat allerdings muss
man dazu sagen schon fast ein Drittel
der ukrainischen Bevölkerung als ihren
Häusern vertrieben aber die allermeisten
und das ist in der Debatte hier wichtig
sind in der Ukraine geblieben
vergangenen Ende des Winters genau
April es gibt einen Tag 15 April aus dem
ersten Mal mehr Ukraine aus Polen
zurückgehen als kommen wir haben
eigentlich die letzten Monate eine
Rückkehr gehabt weil das sind Frauen ist
in Kinder vor allem die zurück wollen zu
ihren Vätern jede Männern fällt die
Elektrizität immer wieder aufs Neue aus
die Heizung fällt aus und wir sprechen
jetzt über Eiskalte Temperaturen jetzt
mit Blick auf die nächsten anderthalb
Wochen Dauerfrost in der Ukraine das ist
eine eine Katastrophe es ist auch ein
permanentes Kriegsverbrechen das auch
zeigt wie Ernstes Vladimir Putin meint
auch wieder die Stadt cashorn wie die
übergeben wurde alles zerstört da kann
man im Winter nicht leben und daher
müssen wir uns jetzt darauf einstellen
wenn wir diese Erpressung nicht
standhalten wollen aber den Konsens in
der Gesellschaft bewahren wollen dass
wir in Deutschland in Europa in den
Ländern und das sind zum Glück die
meisten nicht alle aber die meisten die
bereit sind Leute aufzunehmen dass wir
uns so organisieren dass das über diesen
Winter hinaus bis zum April funktioniert
darüber sprechen wir gleich und Details
Herr Müller haben sie für Berlin gehen
im Moment ein Überblick wie viele
Menschen aus der Ukraine wie viele
Flüchtlinge man da insgesamt in den
vergangenen Monaten mittlerweile
aufgenommen hat und gut 90.000 das ist
ungefähr auch vergleichbar mit denen die
2015/2016 gekommen sind das war auch
innerhalb von acht Wochen sind ungefähr
100.000 sind zusätzlich in die Stadt
gekommen das natürlich eine
Riesenaufgabe man will den Menschen ja
auch gut helfen das heißt es geht darum
gute Unterkünfte zu schaffen in einer
Stadt die ohnehin schon eng ist und dann
einen riesen Bevölkerungswachstum hat
und
nicht funktioniert im Alter ja aber wir
haben ja auch 100.000 Syrien und Syrern
helfen können wir helfen jetzt 90.000
Menschen aber es geht ja auch nicht nur
um Wohnraum es geht um ärztliche
Versorgung und Beschulung für die Kinder
es geht um Kleidung um Nahrungsmittel es
geht um eine Perspektive wie leicht auch
über den April hinaus es geht um
Integrationsarbeit und das ist natürlich
nicht nur für Berlin für die Städte und
gucken Bürgermeisterin hat gesagt sie
befindet sich die Hauptstadt jetzt im
Grunde an der Kapazitätsgrenze das heißt
wenn wir jetzt sprechen über eine neue
Flüchtlingsbewegung möglicherweise
massiv sie können nicht mehr in Berlin
ich frage immer wie ist der
Umkehrschluss deswegen zucke ich auch
bei dem Begriff für migrationskrise oder
flüchtlingskrise
oder
wortkapazitäten müssen wollen wir die
Menschen alleine lassen sie kommen aus
bitterer not sie können in Ihrem Land
was ja die beste Lösung wäre können sie
nicht bleiben wegen der Zustände die wir
gehört haben das heißt sie machen sich
aus guten Grund auf um sich und ihre
Familie zu schützen und wir wollen der
Ukraine helfen militärisch diplomatisch
wie auch immer aber es ist doch auch
unsere humanitäre Pflicht den Menschen
auf der Flucht zu helfen und insofern
auch wenn es für uns eine Belastung ist
und es ist eine Belastung kann man nicht
weg diskutieren es ist auch unsere
Aufgabe weiter zu helfen wenn Sie das
Hören gleichzeitig dieses Dilemma spüren
bei Herrn Müller Herr Ramsauer hat das
bei sich als Berchtesgaden geschildert
einerseits der Wille zu helfen auf der
anderen Seite ganz klar zu sagen die
Kapazitätsgrenze ist erreicht wie würden
sie es auflösen
ja Gott sei Dank ist nicht meine Aufgabe
ist aufzulösen ich kann es beschreiben
es ist es ist an der Grenze und so sehen
sich die Gemeinden und Landkreise dass
es man mit den Ukrainern eigentlich bis
oben auf voll ist und jetzt kommt eben
noch die Zuwanderung weil die
Balkanroute über ein Grunde alle
deutschen Grenzen hinzu wo wir eine
illegale Migration haben die im
Asylantrag endet und das ist inzwischen
auch im Steigen begriffen und wir gehen
auch da auf Werte von 2015 16
Ramsauer sagt wir sind jetzt dabei die
Turnhallen wieder zu öffnen das ist was
was glaube ich im Bevölkerung erst recht
nach der coronazeit niemand möchte und
nach den Erfahrungen von 25 152 16
würden sie das tun oder Beispiel
Hauptstadt Berlin die Hauptstadt die
Bürgermeisterin sagt wir sind an der
Kapazitätsgrenze also was jetzt tun in
Berlin werden Zelte gebaut auf dem
Flughafen Tegel und es wird gesagt das
sind das ist aber nicht Moria
also dass man man setzt sich moralisch
ab und macht sich besser und
gleichzeitig macht man im Grunde genau
das gleiche was
sie sprechen gerade
nicht gewesen sein
in diesem Lager gab es einen
Zusammenbruch der Staatlichkeit und
Kontrolle da gab es Vergewaltigungen wo
sich die Polizei nicht hineingetraut hat
das sind auf engster also da ist Berlin
da ist Deutschland so mein Wert davon
entfernt aber wir bauen Zelte ja wir
bauen machen wieder auf das ist der
Winter
helfen wir haben Wohnung zur Verfügung
gestellt die Bundesebene landeseigene
Liegenschaften wir haben Container
gebaut wir nehmen andere Unterkünfte
große eben weil sie Institutionen die
ihre Räumlichkeiten nicht brauchen aber
wir sind jetzt an einer an einem Punkt
wo wir auch mit Zelten so schlimm es ist
helfen wollen und helfen müssen weil
sonst haben die Menschen gar keine
Situation wo sie irgendwie an diesen
Winter überstehen